we have continuing coverage of the
breaking news from Helsinki Finland
where President Trump and President
Putin are holding a historic summit
joining us now is in Bremer Eurasia
group president and CBS News senior
global affairs contributor he has new
information about what happened in the
lead-up to this summit good morning
again in the lead up being the president
was with NATO leaders what happened at
that meeting it was we saw the rumbles
what was going on behind the scenes a
few things one is that emergency session
where they asked the Georgian Ukrainian
presidents to leave in the middle of
their presentation apparently Trump's
like okay we're done with you now one
thing they did is Trump was very
frustrated that he wasn't getting
commitments from other leaders to spend
more and many of them said well we have
to ask our Parliament's we have a
process we can't just tell you we're
going to spend more the legal process
Trump turns around to the Turkish
president Retta Berta Juan and says
except for the one over here he does
things the right way and then actually
fist-bumps the Turkish president so if
you want to talk about to what extent
the allies are comfortable with Trump as
opposed to the strongman leader what we
saw in the g20 with that second meeting
what we see now with NATO and the Putin
meeting this is a very visible
suggestion of remind people why
Europeans would be nervous for the
American president to be heralding the
Turkish leader who has no real domestic
opposition of course I mean after his
executive presidency the the purges that
have gone on internally I mean turkey is
a hardly a liberal democracy at this
point another thing that was interesting
is that apparently the dutch Prime
Minister Mark Rutte ax was the last
person to intervene at the summit before
Trump had his press conference that was
so extraordinary basically said look
you're really frustrated why don't you
just take a victory lap say that the
Allies have been spending thirty three
billion dollars more became before but
since you became president take credit
for it that was the last thing Trump
heard before he left the meeting and
it's the first thing we said which would
make a fist bump really unattractive and
disturbing to people the universal sign
of a way to go good job but what do you
make of the comments
two men made President Putin and
President Trump before they sat down
together what do you make of their
comments well I think interesting that
Trump specifically talked about China
talked about China a fair bit more than
any other thing he mentioned did not
mention Russian meddling in that did not
mention what promised he will talk about
it for one thing that you didn't say
later Arnold say well of course you know
I'm about to go into the meeting he's
sitting right there I want to do that
privately but obviously it's interesting
but you know there are many people that
do believe that long term the United
States and Russia should have a good
relationship China is the problem China
is the emerging superpower China is
actually the true competitor undermining
the Americans and also undermining the
Russians long term and I think that was
Steve bannon's view when he was the
chief strategist for the White House I
think it's interesting that trumps
clearly turning against Beijing the 200
billion dollars announced in tariffs
that may be coming down the unhelpful
'no smore recently a North Korea from
his perspective I think he'd love to
sense if he can move putting on that the
other big thing he said was
denuclearization we're gonna have to
leave it there even though you have one
more big thing that's gonna go thank you
very much II and always good to have you
at the table